Hi everyone - Emily here for DNews.
Frog tongues are sticky - and extremely fast.
They can capture insects five times faster
than you can blink, and grab mice and birds
that weigh up to 1.4 times the frog itself.
For a long time, scientists didn’t have
a full understanding of how that was possible,
but a new study published in the Journal of
the Royal Society Interface uncovered the
true nature of the frog tongue.
The researchers discovered that frogs are
able to catch their prey because their tongue
is incredibly soft and is coupled with saliva
that changes its viscosity — or its thickness
— depending on the situation.
Here’s how it works.
When a frog goes to capture its prey, it slaps
its tongue at the victim.
Because of its squishy, soft nature, the tongue
curls around the prey and acts like a shock
absorber — taking in the energy of the impact
and preventing the food from bouncing away.
A frog’s tongue is about 10 times softer
than a human’s, which allows it to be 10
times as stretchy, spreading out over a large
area of its victim.
This larger contact area gives it better adhesion
so it doesn’t drop its food.
Once the tongue makes contact with a fly,
mouse, or bird, then the saliva goes to work.
The saliva is a non-Newtonian fluid, which
is a fancy way of saying that it’s a fluid
that doesn’t follow normal fluid rules.
Unlike regular liquids - like water - a non-Newtonian
fluid can change its thickness under pressure.
A frog’s saliva, for example, gets thinner
when the tongue smacks its food.
This allows the spit to spread over the prey.
As the tongue retracts, the saliva becomes
thicker and effectively holds onto the victim.
Once the food enters its mouth, the frog sinks
its eyeballs into its head to exert pressure
on the tongue and force the food down.
This also thins the saliva again, causing
the prey to slide off the tongue and go down
the frog’s throat.
Scientists have long studied the stickiness
of amphibian and reptile tongues to try and
learn more about adhesives.
But so far, we have yet to develop a synthetic
material that can match the speed and versatility
of a frog’s tongue.
Now that we know more about how a frog captures
its prey, this could inspire the design of
reversible adhesives that could work at high
speeds.
One example could be at a manufacturing plant
where you had to pick up delicate components
quickly from a conveyor belt.
Another researcher suggested that it could
lead to the possibility of drones fitted with
artificial frog tongues that could grab objects
in flight.
So if you’re looking to grab things on the
go fast, just consult a frog.
If you want to know more about frogs, check
out this video on weird frog discoveries here.
What about you?
Is this the most you ever thought about frog
tongues?
Let us know in the comments, subscribe and
come back here for more DNews every day.